Шановні колеги
Шановний пане міністри Я думаю що ви
відволічеться від дуже важливих дискусій
Я Хочу наголосити на тому що це вперше
коли ми приймаємо такий важливий
документ в такий важливий час не маючи
головних розпорядників більше того цього
зал відмовився їх слухати не маючи уряд
а
Шановний пане міністр в мене до нього
питань нема він компетентний професійний
ще з часів роботи в моєї команді але
сьогодні він є адвокатом не своєї справи
цей бюджет написаний не в міністерстві
фінансів
цей бюджет
логіки парламент ми Верховна Рада
представники народу не місце для
дискусії і я думаю що
логіка цього є зменшення фінансування на
оборону під час війни і збільшення
фінансування карального апарату А навіщо
збільшується
збільшується ті хто переслідує бізнес а
через такий шлях Вони збираються
збільшити зростання економіки для того
щоб давати більше молока корову треба
менше годувати і більше доїти
В мене є Дежавю коли ми
21-му році в жовтні місяці дали проект
змін до бюджету по збільшенню
фінансування армії перед війною Нам
казали що це не потрібно коли ми
вимагали забрати гроші з дорожнього
фонду передати їх на боротьбу з квітами
Нам казали що це не потрібно Зараз коли
забирають гроші в Міноборони і передають
їх він страдпрому нам кажуть що це для
оборони А з якого біса ви взяли що
Міноборони має купляти тільки в іноземці
а не
своїми коштами стимулювати місцеве
виробництво Якщо ви хочете стимулювати
самі Мінськ спра-пром дайте бюджетне
кредитування щоб хтось хоч відповідав що
ці гроші не будуть вкрадені як це зараз
відбувається ті що днів а нарешті
коли-небудь повернуться до державного
бюджету це принцип європейський а
принцип розкрадання завтра вони
організують що буде підірване це
виробництво А гроші десятки мільярдів
будуть списані заберіть гроші Він
весняні які руйнують конкурентне
середовище заберіть гроші в
індустріальних партіях і тоді направте
всі ці гроші на Міністерство оборони
принцип який має бути сповіданий нікому
не підвищувати видатки за виключенням
Міністерства оборони збройних сил
України наших воїнів Слава збройним
силам України і слава Україні